les messages de soutien continuent à se
multiplier pour remercier les équipes
soignantes et les personnes touchées par
la maladie avec nous en plateau mathilde
de 2min journalistes de la rédaction
bonsoir bonsoir une chanteuse yvelinoise
a voulu mettre sa pierre à l'édifice et
elle est notre invité et oui s'essayer à
terra bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
chanteuse dans les yvelines et vous avez
récemment fait une reprise de la chanson
je ne vous oublie pas de céline dion en
l'adaptant pour les personnes qui
exercent des métiers et qui les place en
première ligne face au chaos coronavirus
comment vous est venue l'idée
alors je pense que la volonté première a
été un petit peu comme tous les artistes
de faire savoir aux acteurs du quotidien
et surtout principalement à nos
soignants qu'on pense à eux et que bon
la situation très particulière fait que
nos actions sont limitées mais en tant
qu'artiste j'ai j'ai eu cette volonté de
leur signifier qu'on pensait à tout
simplement
donc on ne vous oublie pas c'est le nom
de votre cover comment vous avez écrit
des paroles alors les paroles m'ont été
inspirées par le contexte actuel et de
je ne vous oublie pas c'est devenu on ne
vous oublie pas avec
cette volonté de faire apparaître des
familles également confiné parce que
j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir collaborer
avec mon ami de toujours so elle tire
avec un grand musicien au grand coeur
qui a réinterprété du coup le la musique
et de là nous est venue donc l'idée
assisté de ma famille de réaliser un
clip est de faire collaborer
plusieurs familles confiné alors on ne
s'attendait pas à recevoir autant de
deux manifestations montant de vidéos
lorsqu'on a fait l'appel sur les réseaux
et c'est vrai que paradoxalement ce
confinement nous a beaucoup rapprochés
je me suis aussi appuyé sur sur des sur
des personnes précieuse donc notamment à
liste marque qui est une photographe qui
a réalisé récemment toute une série de
photos qu'elle a intitulé les jocondes
où elle a elle a pris des portraits de
deux femmes palmans soignantes et donc
du coup ça a considérablement enrichi
enrichi ce clip il ya eu également
l'intervention importante d'un
réalisateur qui s'appelle le grand qui
entre-temps a très vite compris ce
projet là et qui nous a donné son som
concours précieux pour réaliser avec un
grand professionnalisme
7 ce clip c'est un bon sens pour vous de
remercier à votre façon des personnes
qui sont en première ligne
mais bien évidemment ces mêmes ces mêmes
prioritaire quand j'ai envie de dire
parce que aujourd'hui les personnes qui
maintienne notre niveau de vie sont ceux
qu'on ne voit pas je pense notamment aux
éboueurs ou aux commerçants pour qu'on a
l'habitude quand même de voir quand on
va faire nos courses mais il ya aussi
également le le personnel soignant lui
est au coeur de tout et qui permet de
sauver des vies bon an mal an on se doit
d'y penser donc il ya cette
manifestation la importante à 20 heures
tous les soirs où plusieurs personnes
manifestent ce soutien ça je trouve que
c'est très important et qu'on a tous
qu'on a tous un devoir en ce sens en
tout cas pour savoir qu'on est là merci
c'est l'intérêt d'avoir répondu à nos
questions et on va vous remercier à un
extrait avant de passer à la
on ne vous oubliera
boudra pétain
pour nos vies pour que s'écrivent à
venir